foreign
the biggest risk we have every single
night is safety and it became so
critically important to have the right
people and the right personalities that
we had to build a system to measure
those personalities and that's in the
recruiting vetting process oh yeah how
do you measure those things humility
we created essentially a scorecard it
has six questions per category so six
for humility six for work ethics six
four emotional intelligence questions
like do the energy they bring every
night is it consistent as a positive so
we talk about body language and
emotional intelligence and all these
different things within these questions
and I'm happy to like provide this thing
and we use it in three ways
we give it to the person on the second
interview and we're hiring somebody so
we say here's the HHS system this is the
only thing you're accountable to in your
first month and two things happen they
read it and they go or actually they
just don't call back
and I've made a ton of hiring mistakes
in the past where
you get past this honeymoon phase and
people turn into grouches and yeah
there's people first by Halley's
involves I remember a guy that we were
going to hire that was a like brilliant
electrical engineer who wanted to quit
his job come work with us because he
heard about the seven and seven schedule
and thought it'd be the best thing ever
and then he read it and he didn't call
me back
and I I really wanted to hire him and
and I called him back and I said any
reason you didn't call me back he's like
I have terrible body language and I'm
not willing to quit my job and take the
chance within the first month that I get
fired for bad body language because we
score them if you're an a we celebrate
and figure out a way for you reward you
if you're a b we like find immediate
improvements that you need to make
within some of these categories and if
you are a c we let you go on the spot no
questions asked
and you set that expectation up front oh
so we said that in the interview they
have to like agree to this system coming
in they're evaluated by their entire
team including them doing a self eval
which is a part of the overall score
they get to like grade themselves and
the team do they are they sent on like a
test evening
prior to hiring or I guess they just
know that once they start going out yeah
so we call them tryouts but when
somebody comes to try out with us which
means we give them a month we we hire
them on but we call them a tryout and at
the end of that tryout that which is
typically a one month period they get
graded by their entire team and they
know it's this like really tense moment
where how many people are on a given
team eight to ten got it yeah so it's a
good average so if somebody yeah if
somebody's got to bug up their ass about
somebody just one person it it always
ends up being like a great average and
it always ends up being a great measure
of that person it's been this
extraordinary filter for hiring
asshole's the wrong word but when we
figured out how to use that system we
now grade every person at their first
month we grade every single person
quarterly including me every single
person gets graded and there's questions
on there like do they try or ask to do
more than is required of them every day
um and it's been so amazing to see the
mistakes I make in when we're hiring new
people or moving people around like a
great example is
I moved a couple people from a field
position into a management position and
then all of a sudden their work ethic
score started coming down and it wasn't
because they weren't working any harder
it was I didn't do a good job defining
to the team what their new
responsibilities were so they saw them
sitting on a computer and doing these
things and they're like well they're not
in the field helping us and so it's just
this amazing quarterly exercise that
just pulls out all of the tension within
your teams and creates framework for
people to address those tensions and
then ultimately what's amazing is to
watch people grow
how do you give feedback let's say they
come back and they've got a bunch of
bees what's the big boss do yeah so we
sit them down and we say
is that the Royal way or is it just you
no no it's it's multiple people yeah
it's me and like the two or three other
Harvest managers got it
great example one of the questions we
asked talks about do they are they
genuinely happy to see their teammates
succeeding because safety is such an
important part of what we do when we
bring somebody in that's more talented
just like a sports team moves the best
people into the best positions we
immediately move people around positions
based on their skill sets so somebody
has to be genuinely happy to train
somebody that may replace them in a role
that they may enjoy yeah they used to be
the yeah like right Striker or whatever
exactly got replaced and it's amazing to
watch somebody that really wants to be
there because they find purpose and they
really love the schedule and they know
the impact that they're having to our
community have to make the decision
to be better for their teammate every
night to be like celebrating that
person's growth even though it's
potentially coming at the cost of
something that they enjoy yeah so
there's these that's hard oh I mean I'm
not saying it's unreasonable but that I
mean that's that's asking a lot of a lot
of people and I don't know if I would be
honest with myself I think that'd be
hard here's the thing like it's been
such a amazing exercise with lots of
iterations right yeah like the first
three iterations I made so many grown
men cry and I felt so bad
was that your delivery or the
measurement were you just like it was
just the permission [__] face it was the
measurement
no you're getting evaluated by your
peers yeah on your personality and the
value it's bringing to your team yeah
and you have to sit down quarterly and
like be told
your humility is not good enough for
this team I assume that the responses
are all anonymized yeah everything's
anonymized so and then average for what
it's worth so I've done what's called a
360 interview right and I know people
who as Executives or Founders have had
these done and
without exception and myself included
every time that I spoke to somebody
who's experienced this for the first
time they're like I went and they sat in
my car oh and I basically had like a
nervous breakdown crisis of meaning
what do I do
like these are names everybody would
recognize but they were just like
holy [__] yeah the first time we did it
with a large enough team that I included
myself in it because we were just so
small early on it was I think like the
third iteration I was like I need to be
a part of this and I got all of the
feedback back I was just like oh my God
but if we really want to build
extraordinary teams like I realized my
approach to some of our conversations
yeah had to be
so much better and nuanced to make to
make them better and like it wasn't the
right approach and you learn all of this
you end up reading this thing like
Braille after doing it I've done it like
hundreds of times now yeah and I mean
with repetition I imagine yeah that's
like exercise right it's like okay
you're gonna do Plyometrics once a year
you're going to be very very very sore
yeah and you might even hurt yourself
but if you're doing it but it was
amazing to see what happens we built
this system because we knew we had to go
from like eight people to 45 in a really
short period of time to hit our mission
goals about a year and a half ago and
I had made poor hiring decisions in the
past and they were mostly
personality based or they were that
person was operating
amazing when I was around but the minute
I left they turned into a different
person and then there's this he said she
said game this completely erases all of
that yeah because it's Anonymous team
scoring and the manager doesn't have a
unweighted vote on whether that person
stays around and what ended up happening
is we that HHS program started
attracting people they started hearing
about this accountability process to
ensure you're attracting better fits oh
yeah so coming back to so you're not
saying Hey [__] face yeah in like the
fourth fifth 10th 20th iteration yeah
what's the language that you use
if somebody has growth opportunities
that's great it's really specific to
which of the 18 categories they're
struggling in right like how does the
meeting start okay so we sit down and we
we're gonna give them paper and we say
like okay you're a B minus Yeah Tim we
put a 250 pound animal on your back you
crumpled into an Oregon Crane and you
couldn't get up so you're a B minus and
then we celebrate first some of the
categories that they're doing really
well in like some of the categories that
point to professionalism or energy or
all these different things we celebrate
right away because they're each one of
the 24 segments have different scores
within them that have been averaged
throughout their team and then we
address the ones that they're like a c
in and
a great example a lot of our young guys
that come on board got it so they're not
cut if they have a c in a particular
Viewpoint it's the average yeah so the C
average and it's been amazing to see
that system work
I've let go several people that were C's
that I would have never let go
I wouldn't have known to let them go
yeah like wouldn't have known that that
was the impact they were having on the
team at large it just would have never
come out yeah I would love to you
mentioned I think you offered to maybe
share oh absolutely question so we'll
put that in the show notes as well yeah
team.blog podcast because I'm I'm
incredibly curious to check it out
myself it's just at least at face value
it seems like a very elegant solution to
a lot of problems that can seem like
fragmented separate problems you have to
address in different ways I've Heard
lots of people's
and again like I'm just a system builder
and by no means is it perfect but I've
heard lots of people speak to how
important these different personality
traits are and how they reward them and
more importantly than the c or the A's
being able to like say to somebody this
incredible combination of like humility
work ethic and emotional intelligence is
making your whole team better yeah and
your whole team is telling you your
extraordinary active things being able
to reward and compensate somebody for
that and have a measure to do so you say
compensate so let's say they have
because I know this is getting the weeds
yeah bit but I feel like yep that's
where a lot of the good stuff is hiding
so
how many questions were there again
there's 18 questions six on humility six
on work ethic and six on emotional
intentions and they get this like a b or
c for each of those questions there it's
graded one through seven yeah we just
did it because it was seven days of the
week and we talk about like being at
excellent every day
so it's one through seven and then we
add up all the scores which is 126 total
and they get a percentage so if they're
in 87 we give them a B plus which is the
average which is the average how do you
reward or compensate the A's if they're
in their first sixth month of employment
and they get two like A's or a pluses in
a reward we give them a raise based on
that contribution and then we celebrate
with the team like
no was it was an a this last quarter
like we make sure the team knows the
contribution that they're having and
it's already which is so interesting
they already all know yeah right but to
not have framework to reward them for
being amazing people has always been
this fuzzy place for me where I couldn't
like
reward or compensate that person for
being an extraordinary individual that
was making their whole team better
because it didn't fit into what the
classic hard skills Define as like
they're a great shooter or they're a
great driver or one of these different
things and every single one of those a
plus people are our most highly skilled
people as well when you operate with a
certain level of humility you are more
willing to learn yeah right and you
learn faster yeah totally and every
single person that's come through our
program that was like a B minus or a c
that was like highly skilled and made
the choice not to get better at these
but I very much consider like skills
just weeded themselves out yeah yeah
it's been it's been really cool to see
people grow and like you're in this camp
and you see these guys with their their
a lot of them will tape their score up
above their bed
and they'll like look at it in the
morning and say like okay my job is to
make I was a B minus in this thing I
need to bring more consistent energy
overnight we've got guys that go up and
down and up and down and they're like
okay I'm gonna be trying to be more
consistent like they know what they're
working on